ces panneaux pourrait bientôt retrouver
un visage organiser le deuxième tour des
élections municipales dès la fin du mois
de juin le conseil scientifique ne s'y
opposent pas mais parmi les dijonnais
les avis divergent
je pense que c'est nécessaire que
rapidement on en finisse et que ce désir
et tour ait lieu en juin
si on peut reporter côtière à moindre
risque et ben je pense que ça sera mieux
je suis pour faire les refaire les deux
tours voilà je suis pas pour faire
simplement une campagne de trois jours
pour le maire de dijon l'avis du conseil
scientifique est évidemment une bonne
nouvelle il y a quelques jours il avait
signé une tribune réclamant justement la
tenue du second tour en juin pour
remettre la commune en ordre de marche
70% de l'investissement public c'est
nous ceux des collectivités locales et
donc si on veut être là pour accompagner
un grand plan de relance
moi je pense je les dis à la ministre
pour qu'il y ait une rénovation
thermique des bâtiments par exemple ça
ça serait un verdissement de l'économie
on est prêt encore faut-il qu'on en ait
les moyens juridiques et politiques
ces deux opposants comptent aussi sur un
second tour a rapidement même si les
actions menées par la mairie pendant
l'épidémie pourra jouer en leur défaveur
je suis sereine chacun va bien faire la
part des choses et puis bah voilà de
toute façon encore une fois le but c'est
qu'on puisse repartir maintenant dans un
véritable débat débat démocratique et
surtout qu'on puisse terminer ce tour
des municipales pour que l'on puisse
passer à autre chose et notamment à
comment on envisage la reprise
économique pour la tenue du second tour
le conseil scientifique préconise des
mesures sanitaires très strictes
le candidat les républicains fait une
proposition en ce sens c'est de demander
publiquement qu'on instaure la
possibilité de voter par correspondance
circuler les électeurs aient le choix
entre se rendre aux urnes ou renvoyer
une enveloppe cachetée avec leur vote
je crois que ça nous permet de nous
mettre à l'abri de tous les aléas
d'évolution d'épidémique c'est
maintenant au gouvernement de décider si
le second tour pourra bien se tenir en
juin